Join me now to weigh in on all this.
He's the director of Jihad Watch, which
you should be watching out for that. We
just had two attacks in the homeland
last week. And he's the author of the
book Holy Hell: Islam's Abuse of Women
and the Infidels Who Enable It, Robert
Spencer, back on the program. Mr.
Spencer, how are you, sir?
Just great, Dan. Always good to talk to
you. So, um
look, I've been raising the alarm bells
here for years about and I quit using
the R-word. I don't say radical Islam
because even the moderate ones and the
peaceful ones are just 1 minute away
from getting triggered to kill the
infidels because their book tells them
to lie and to kill the infidels. And I'm
an infidel because I'm a Christian and I
don't believe in what they're
spewing. So, my question is, in your
Jihad Watch, cuz that's what you head
up, should we be more worried now
because of the strikes in Iran for more
homegrown terror or sleeper cells or
lone wolves popping up here in America?
Absolutely, Dan. Uh because look, in the
first place,
we're at a tremendous disadvantage
because nobody has been paying attention
to this threat. As a matter of fact,
even to this day, the US government does
not acknowledge that there is such a
thing as Islamic Jihad. The president
has talked about it, but Barack Obama,
when he was president in 2011, removed
all mention of Islam from counter-terror
training.
>> that.
That was everybody raised I mean, some
people on the right raised a big fuss
over that and said, "Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa. Is that because you're a Muslim?"
And I think he declared that he was a
Christian, allegedly. But why would you
pull that
verbage? Yeah, go ahead.
Well, he wanted to clearly he wanted to
cozy up to the Islamic Republic of Iran
and other Muslim countries. He wanted to
placate and appease the growing Muslim
population in the United States. And so,
he hamstrung Now, it's 15 years,
hamstrung our counter-terror apparatus
because they can't study the motives of
the enemy. And that is just a recipe for
failure as we know the oldest adage in
warfare is know your enemy and uh we are
prevented from doing that. And so these
guys are coming in and establishing
Sharia enclaves and the people who are
dealing with them in law enforcement and
intelligence have no idea what they're
dealing with or the implications of it.
And they have most American politicians
and public officials have no idea that
Islam is more than a religion but is
also political and is not just political
but violent.
>> It's a political ideology cult, in my
opinion, Robert, and I'll tell you what,
last week's attack on the synagogue in
Michigan and then the Old Dominion
school prove it. And let me go to
Michigan and say something. You heard
from that sheriff say, "We just went
through some training in the last couple
of weeks to warn folks there might be
some attacks because you got Dearborn
15-20 minutes away from where that
attack happened, right?" Well, for the
last how many years, since Obama,
Americans were told if you said anything
about Islam or Muslims, you were
Islamophobic.
And so it scared good conservative
Christians and American Christians and
Jews kind of to the sideline like, "Oh
my god, I can't ever say anything bad or
they'll call me Islamophobic." I'm
sorry, it doesn't belong. It doesn't go
in this republic. It doesn't go with our
Judeo-Christian beliefs. Their Sharia
laws are anti everything we stand for.
And they're inhumane as well. And I
can't believe there's Americans out
there, there's Catholics out there. I
won't throw her name out there on my
show, but there's idiots out there,
Robert, literally trying to say,
"Catholics unite with Islam and Muslims
against these Zionist Christians." Are
you stupid? Muslims want us all dead.
Maybe not all of them, but the leaders
of Iran sure as hell do. That's why
they've been saying death to America for
47 years.
Yep. And look, I couldn't agree more.
It's not just Catholics, but I see it.
It's a concerted propaganda effort, and
I see it among Catholic Christians,
Protestant Christians, Orthodox
Christians, that they say the real
problem is the Jews, and we have to
unite with the Muslims
>> Right.
>> to deal with the Zionist threat. In the
first place, there is no Zionist threat,
and in the second place, there is
actually a religion that is, as I said a
minute ago, violent, supremacist,
aggressive, and expansionist, and that
is not Judaism, but Islam.
>> Yeah, I know. Let me
real quick before I lose you, Robert,
cuz I want people to
Sorry to interrupt you, but I want
people to see this before I lose you,
cuz I know you got to run, and I'm
almost out of time. Put the headline up.
Uh I think David Harris Jr. might have
posted this, my friend or somebody,
about all the mosques that have popped
up in America just in the last decade or
two. Look at these numbers, folks. This
is scary. So, a lot of our Christian
churches and some Jewish synagogues
closed down during COVID, especially,
and they were out snatching up these
down in Florida, New York, California,
Texas. Look at these numbers. 570
in New York City, 399 mosques in Texas,
481 in California, 250 in Florida, and
the list goes on and on. And there are
clerics, they're imams, they call them.
These imams are inside these mosques,
folks, right now, this week, the last 2
weeks,
saying death to America, telling people
Islam will be in every American
household, whether you like it or not,
and kill the infidels. They're not
saying it in Iran anymore, they're
saying it here on the homeland, Robert.
Final word to you with a few seconds
left.
Well, a lot Most of those mosques were
established in just the last few years.
Most Muslims in the United States have
come here since 9/11. This is a
colonialist project. The left is all
worried about colonialism, except when
it's the United States that's being
colonized. This is a project designed to
replace our system with another system
that denies the freedom of speech,
equality of rights to women, equality of
rights to non-Muslims, and much more.
And most people are asleep and not aware
of this threat even to this day. Yeah.
Well, and the disinformation information
war out there coming from folks on the
radical left and right because there's
people on both sides now spewing hate
towards certain Christians and certain
Jews while cozying up to Islam scares
the hell out of me because that is the
total wrong and opposite direction we
should be going. Robert Spencer, thank
you. The book's called Holy Hell. He's
the director of Jihad Watch. Appreciate
you, Robert.
Great to talk to you, Dan. Thank you.
Yep.